welcome to Sky forge a new MMORPG where
your goal is to transform yourself from
an immortal hero into a mighty God there
are a huge number of paths you can take
to reach your goal the tool which shows
you these character progression paths
and helps you choose your way is called
the ascension atlas it displays all the
directions in which you may develop your
character as you travel along your
chosen path new nodes unlock before you
each new node means new abilities and
better stats the more nodes you unlock
the more powerful you become your combos
will be more sophisticated your attacks
deadlier and you will learn new
spectacular skills the ascension Atlas
is not the only distinctive part of
character progression in skyforge we
also left the common notion of class
selection behind are you tired of the
paladin's combat style always having to
tank in the middle of a big crowd switch
to a gunner class and kill your foes at
range in Skyforge you are free to switch
your character to any of the ten classes
available at launch there is no need to
real evelope with each new class you
unlock because your character's power
and progress is maintained across all of
your classes the option of easily
switching between classes and combat
roles is particularly convenient when
playing in a group if your party likes a
tank or a decent support character no
problem just change your class and
you're good to go
this means groups can devise their own
composition for any boss fight Skye
forges innovative class selection and
development makes the Ascension Atlas a
powerful and flexible tool for
developing your character
millions of ways to combine your skills
and styles making each character truly
unique you can always find the latest
skyforge chronicles releases news and
project updates and sign up for beta on
skyforge dot-com and by following us on
your favorite social network